220 gendarmes mobilisés ces jours ci
dans 27 départements pour démanteler un
réseau de trafic d'image pédophiles sur
internet au total l'opération a donné
lieu à 66,1 appel assure libye caroff la
longue traque a été piloté d'ici for the
run voici la cellule de veille internet
de la gendarmerie
ce service spécialisé à remonter une
filière de distribution d' images
pédophiles page web après page web
l'adresse email en forums de discussions
qu'il aura fallu trois ans de travail
pour retrouver la véritable identité de
ceux qui diffusent et de ceux qui
reçoivent des documents pornographiques
mettant en scène des mineurs
depuis ce matin soixante six personnes
sont en état d'arrestation une opération
d'envergure baptisé forum 51 les
enquêteurs dirigés par un juge
d'instruction de troy ont trouvé chez
une quinzaine de suspects des disquettes
et des cd rom contenant des scènes de
pédophilie
d'autres expertises sont en cours sur
les disques durs elles permettront de
savoir qui faisait quoi dans ce réseau à
l'origine de la sphère la plainte d'une
association le bouclier son président a
porté plainte en 98 et il se sent
toujours bien seul dans ce combat contre
la pédophilie
on peut pas se satisfaire du fait qu'en
cinq ans il y est eu deux opérations
d'une certaine envergure et uniquement à
l'initiative d'une association
je crois que la puissance publique n'est
pas à sa place sur le site internet du
bouclier tout est prévu pour la
cybertraque si vous trouvez un site
pédophile
une rubrique spéciale vous attend pour
le dénoncer jeu